so congratulations guys on your
successors property deal sources thank
you very much so you guys are now making
how much a month
so about
over five days so in the last three
months 20k altogether
so
money that you're making now you do
property full time now yeah finishing
three for me i'm i'm not quite um
full-time because i'm doing my teacher
training but i've got about two weeks
two weeks and then you've been able to
do full time yeah yeah well that's
incredible so property would you say
properties completely changed your life
hundred percent definitely i can't go
back to anything else like i make 3k a
week now no other job is giving me that
so
because you're doing a deal every week
every single week yeah so talk to me
about how you got into property and how
this all kind of started um so for me i
started um looking at different videos
and property in that crypto crash course
um that was in november then i signed up
for the dfe and the dual selling
masterclass yeah and i started um that
in about in february um so the first
event of the year and it was it was an
amazing event it changed my whole
perspective on and just value how you
can charge up to
two to five k per deal so that
completely changed my life and then um
that's when i met him um
that's when we you know yeah so end of
february must have called me he was like
you'll come to some of your leads on
crash course i was like
i started googling everything on youtube
watching your videos
went to the crash course
then he said i'm going back to school
but let as much as you can in april for
half time let's do property yeah okay
fine much i watched everything from
still selling packaging the whole stuff
and the videos used to send me from your
course yeah
and april when was it april the 25th
that's when we made our first deal yeah
so it came down for two weeks and we
said let's set a challenge for ourselves
if we don't become financially free in
april then property doesn't work
wow
yeah from february to about april i was
just getting our compliance everything
ready
building a brand fertile properties yeah
and making sure that you know investor
has something to to have to look at you
know and your partners as well are also
in the business right exactly yeah so
your partner works full-time on the
business yeah
and and and you know you've kind of like
really dominated the space how old are
you guys i'm 26 yeah just 10 20 27 all
right cool so tell me about your first
deal and how did you find the deal how
did you find the investor how much did
you charge we want to know everything so
before we actually find our first then
we
we tried to buy a million pound house
with no cash
because i don't know money down no money
down we said you know what listen maybe
we could do it so we went to we lent so
much set your loan arrangements bridging
finance like all the stuff you didn't
tell us to do
and we were just trying to sell a deal
that wasn't um um that didn't wasn't as
a
great deal so we're just trying we're
learning through
our mistakes but after that we've
learned so much and um so that's when we
decided you know what let's just do what
simulators told us
stop doing whatever we think let's just
do find a deal package a deal find an
investor yeah so went from like 20 years
that we went to 20 over 20 viewings 20
viewings
were you going on these viewings um so
yeah the patch was birmingham so we're
looking for service accommodation there
was got apartments yeah things that you
can rent out in short stay let's yeah
okay good so say 20 viewings and and
what was the were you getting a lot of
rejection was it was all rejection oh
rejection that was just um we were not
pre-qualified before yeah because now
now we call up high can i cover your
view and but it will be a company like i
said okay any questions don't worry
we've been discussing the viewing
because there's something open to you
yeah so now before we go without wasting
our time and every viewing show so
pre-qualified now so yeah yeah so but
before we would just go into any
viewings just to making sure we just had
that appointment for the estate agent
and we did learn a lot of skills in
terms of like what works in what
locations and what postcode works
especially in the birmingham area as
well as our patch yeah and i think as
well at the program that you write in
february that was where there was a
couple of blind teenagers exactly right
what happened so they they actually saw
the deal for three thousand pounds on
the that's when my mindset just was
opening in terms of like this is
actually possible we made the newspapers
and everything i don't know if you knew
that but they found a deal found
investor i did help them with it and put
an email out the phone went off the hook
you know you were there on a great
program it completely just changed the
way i think about in terms of valuing
that because yeah it was always taught
you know
growing up you know you work for for
money like but i didn't know that you
know
once you provide value um a good deal
was between
someone who's willing to sell on someone
who's willing to to buy and we are
basically the
middle man and connecting the two
together
we're getting paid for that value not
for the time necessarily how much how
much time did you get into the finance
space three k is the minimum charge yeah
and you did one a week one yeah about
one a week now yeah but took us a while
to get here but now we've got the
processes in terms of like when an
investor
is interested whatever processes from um
from themselves and nda was providing a
spreadsheet of the numbers and the
property proposal and so we do package
it well how do you know that you're
going to be able to sell it like are you
not worried that your investor list is
going to just dry up and you're going to
have no one to sell to now we get
investors like i come to lots of
networking events like your events pin
um even facebook whatsapp group so
there's always investors everywhere
and what we found that the more we're
connecting with people the more events
we're going to we're building
relationships because no one will buy um
that's one thing he taught us on a
program no one is going to buy if they
need to know and like and trust you yeah
so if they if if an investor doesn't um
trust us
doesn't have that trust um with you
they're not really gonna invest in you
that's why we need to it's important to
build relationships especially going to
networking events and we'll find our
most of our investors on whatsapp how
does an investor buy a deal then let's
say let's say you find a really good
deal and you know me from a program and
we're on the same whatsapp group
together
how do you actually
sell the deal
okay so before we
um so what we do first we um we have a
team so we build a team
in terms of
who
in terms of packaging it in terms of
property proposal where it's got the
pictures of the property where you're
close to exactly so you're going to
drive so you're going to get do all you
do you're going to package it up get a
little pack ready yeah let's say i'm
like i'll message you and i'm like hey
i'm not for this deal i'm interested
how do you actually take them an
interesting investor to someone who's
actually paid you okay so first of all
ask your email so you can send an nda
once you send the nda we'll give you a
phone call like i'm going to send you a
proposal and tell us what you mean it
was an mdi and there's a non-disclosure
agreement okay so they can't then steal
the deal
once if they just ignore it one month if
they sign it and then they quit you out
um so there's two ways so first of all i
wouldn't work with estate agents i'm
very close to them so they'll tell us
anyway but yeah that's true and it does
it's a confidential agreement that it
does protect you so legally they're not
even allowed to do that you could sue
them you can take them to court exactly
and you don't you know we don't proceed
with any investors that don't sign the
nba we've had a lot of people try to say
all right let me just get the address of
the property let me go have a look and
say no if you don't sign the nda you're
not going to see any more details about
it so you send them the nba they sign it
yeah once they've signed it you then
send them the full information pack yeah
what happens if people just say oh let
me think about it give me a few days and
and then just
wasting time and then the deal then go
to somebody else there's always
objections there's always objections
yeah
so um after 24 hours we do call you back
hi what did you like about the property
what did you not like about the product
yeah after the proposal yes and the
spreadsheets yeah what did you like did
you like the numbers did you like what
did you like they said oh no i'm not
sure it is quite time sensitive if you
don't want it someone else will take it
and they've been telling us what they've
got let me think about it and the
caller's back that's gone yeah like we
did tell you it's going to go so now
we're training our investors to know
that once we advertise it it's going
because this you know
once we have done our due diligence we
know it's a good deal and once we've
advertised it and some people cover up
three days later oh i'm interested now
it's gone already yeah and those people
will be the people that will quickly buy
next time
because they'll be like oh man i can't
miss out like i did last time bang
you're sort of showing them the the
there's a limited supply but there is a
lot of demand exactly yes the skill of
selling is one of the most important
especially in dual sourcing and is
selling through asking questions instead
of saying just if an investor says in
the objection oh that's fine i want to
think about okay that's right you know
you're asking questions to probe and see
really what's the objective so between
between you as a company then because
you you're doing this 50 50 right yes
you're doing on average at least one
deal a week and you're charging three
grand so that's three brands that's like
fifteen hundred pounds each
what are your expenses what are the
running costs of the business so running
they're not much really is perfect
yeah yeah so so she she because of she
prepares the package in terms of um
the proposal and you need someone smart
on your team that's dealing with all the
admin while you can focus on actually
running the business exactly because
there's that saying what's that saying
um if you want to go faster you go by
yourself you want to go further you go
as a team yeah i find that it really is
you know it really is it's real
especially in the sourcing yeah so what
are the other expenses do you have apart
from your girlfriend petrol
petrol
yeah training training training training
yeah
because you spent i mean just on the
deal in masterclass you spent 2 000
pounds
but then again you make that back on
your first deal exactly you make that
back and more on the first because the
first thing was three thousand so yeah
um that was paid off and that's tax
deductible so all you costs exactly when
you're paying your partner yeah you're
training your petrol you're claiming
that all by anyways and you're only
paying tax on your profit right
yeah so what would you say you've
learned about business rather not just
about property but about running because
deal sourcing is a business yeah so what
have been some of the core lessons that
you've learned about actually we're in
the business it's actually um one of the
key lessons in terms of you know
managing a team
so because we have a team that's also
might have someone that someone's right
at a viewing right now um who's you know
meeting an investor so you know managing
people um also making sure you have the
right processes so we take an investor
on a journey from selling the end date
to the proposal and the spreadsheets to
the terms and conditions the invoice to
them pay yeah the process that we take
the investor so that's some of the
things anything you can follow
don't you mean understanding the actual
operations operations
and who are all these people who are
these guys doing viewings right now
so they've come to crash course as well
yeah
and
that was so the first deal i'm gonna pay
for the
afternoon selling masterclass okay
they've been on the training as well
yeah yeah and then you're what just sort
of like hang out so tell them what to do
basically i just show them the house
and you're just paying them to do
viewings
so i'm trying to systemize the business
yeah yeah yeah cause that's good that's
smart because if you did everything
yourself you wouldn't be able to be here
right now at my house exactly and also
making money but if you outsource the
work you can so that's smart it makes
sense yeah and also i learned um that
business is not really hard it's just
it's just about consistency and
persistence
so you can get 20 knows in a day we just
need one
so some people give up like you can
quote two landlords but like oh no sorry
no company that
this doesn't work no i'm like know what
i'll get one because you have to keep
trying what i would say also is you know
you don't you don't learn to ride it
back by you know by reading the book you
need to take action yeah you need to be
out there doing viewings you need to get
rejections you need to be out there in
the field to actually learn yeah you
know how to actually how to actually you
know because there's certain things you
can read or you can watch but if you're
not actually going to do it then you're
not going to really learn yeah anything
yeah yeah that's true the only way to
learn is to do
you have to actually do it and that's
why my advanced training that's
just it's basically a week of doing you
know
like [ __ ] viewings
trying to sell deals even at the crash
course you know it's you know
yeah it's all about going and teaching
us and be like okay go and find deals
now you know what do you what do your
family and friends think of what you're
doing
so me i hadn't fought for initially i
hadn't told everyone so not many every
not everyone actually knows that so this
is the big reveal
for some people and some people kind of
knew i was in property and um so you
know this is the big bill for yeah
what about yourself what are your
friends and family think um so i've done
a lot of things so i have a psychology
degree just collecting dust like i
didn't even use it anymore so i was in
teaching as well before him
and i told him don't do it like they're
not paying you for the work you're doing
like because i was working like what 12
hour shifts or days really recovering in
the morning making lessons planning
lessons and everything and you're not
getting that much money that 21k was
when i was doing it
you didn't listen
to your teacher but then i was like i'll
come to property you've made that in the
last two months exactly yeah exactly so
yeah everyone's just so proud because
they knew i was going to just because i
never wanted to do 95. yeah it was never
mind
i was always that kid in school selling
luke's aides you know for profit and
making you buying a little you know
buying a phone or this you know i've
always been have that business mindset
yeah from a young age so you know
and i think of a shout out as well
because i think it was am i right
thinking it was the interview that i did
with crept yes yeah got you guys like oh
my gosh have you seen this that was
actually the first winners on the
wednesday i've seen you know and from
that i was like you know what let me
actually have a look into samuel lee's
and the property courses and then you
know that's when i came to your event um
it was in november last year um and then
from then i just never looked back i
probably watched most of the winners on
wednesday yeah everybody told me you're
silly links there's a new one
okay
did you think that you'd be ending up on
the show i actually did write in when i
was one of my goals on the program that
up to appear on summer leagues it feels
surreal like it feels earlier than i
expected yeah
so
and you're living in hertfordshire yeah
and you're living in birmingham so
are you only focusing on learning
sourcing were you looking across the
country everywhere we saw those in
manchester newton keynes yeah birmingham
athletes yeah i don't know i know now as
well you're looking at doing sort of
bigger development deals we did some
training a few weeks ago yeah um what
what what's what's your plans there
what's going on there so um so you open
my eyes to that like when you look at
normal house it's not don't look at the
house what's around the house what's
next in the house what's above the house
he saw the air above the house
you have to come on that way
that's the only one i haven't been to
that's one um i think you got one in
august probably yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so i'm definitely gonna go to
that one development secrets and you
guys are from zimbabwe yes so you moved
here when you were sort of what like ten
eight ten
yeah yeah yeah so um you know being from
being from zimbabwe like is the culture
i mean we were talking a little about
culture in zimbabwe and stuff like that
what what how would you how would you
describe the zimbabwean business culture
is it different
it's very it's like in properties how to
explain to someone that i don't want to
go to work nine to five you're like you
have to work hard i'm like no i work
smart it's it's joy i think i think that
you know the notion of just
people just know that you have to go to
work and get money so the idea of you're
selling the deal for three thousand it
doesn't it's it doesn't click until you
see it happen i remember when we got our
first because the first time we got um
our first deal was two deals that came
in the same day yeah so that just
completed i was like what this is real
that's also the just ready to quit yeah
so probably that's the worst i actually
called him on the day i was like you
know what just follow up on
the guys and just see what he's saying
just just just because he wasn't um
wasn't sure if he was ready to pay that
yeah because we were selling the terms
of conditions yeah for 500. so just pay
5000 pounds and reserve the deal
then according the next day i was like
hi may i maybe see the terms of
conditions oh yeah sorry i meant to pay
i'm letting you right now how's that
okay
i was too nervous about it then um yeah
muscle yeah so then he paid that exact
day and that's when we knew that the
money is in the follow-up yeah to always
follow up yeah and not only did he pay
for that you paid three thousand you
paid the full price yeah we just asked
for 500 and he said three hours like yo
does this did this just happen yeah then
like what couple hours later another
lady as well from yesterday we followed
up again
another three thousand so one day it was
six thousand wow
six grand in one day the day after you
almost quit yeah i didn't feel like you
know what it's not going to work that
was the last financial freedom challenge
as well yeah so just like yo
yeah and then also you watch like doug
who's also i've been on one of the
wednesday good friend of mine zimbabwe
as well
don't don't you know killing me and i
think that's that's one of the reasons
why i like to interview people because
you know you were inspired by craft and
doug and now you're reading on now
there'll be more people that we inspired
and it kind of has a positive rippling
effect
um have you had any deals that have gone
wrong
so we've had an investor who you know
you know uh was paid everything was
going through and then they just turn
around and say you know what i'm not
interested
in the property and we just as as per
the times and conditions because we
don't mind
foreign changing their minds yeah yeah
we only sell things that we tap on
ourselves yeah because the profits over
500 i'm like would you take this one
yeah i'll take this of course it's a
good deal right exactly and that's so
important because when you learn the
skills to sell you know i'm the best
salesman you'll ever meet exactly
i just come to questions to see yourself
sometimes yeah and you've seen that a
lot of the deal selling masterclass you
know you can test for this i'm just on
the phone
selling deals bang bang bang money in
the back money in the bank and when you
see that you can't unsee it
and that's when i knew that you know
property works because when i saw there
was actually one um
one girl that made 10 000 on that
program i remember yeah yeah in one day
yeah so that is complete i can't answer
you can't see that you can't go back to
teaching work for 21 grand a year when
you just saw someone a brand new newbie
on the program make 10 grand in one day
yeah yeah
it's like what but then the the really
important thing as well which i
hopefully drum harm a lot of the
training which is when you know how to
sell really good it's so important to
also make sure that you over deliver on
what you've sold exactly yeah so when
you sell a deal
so i was saying i want to always be
conservative on your numbers
leave room to wow them if they're
unhappy refund them or put it right
because you know with deal selling when
you're selling a lot of deals and you're
making a lot of money um it's important
to make sure your reputation is always
of course there's always going to be
something every business has good
reviews and bad reviews but you need to
make sure that there's no room for any
bad because you're delivering so well
you know which is really important talk
to me about the importance of terms and
conditions and a written agreement with
your investors before you take money
from them yeah we always make sure that
for for example if they don't sign the
terms and conditions that's just showing
an agreement that you know this is the
amount you pay and this is the amount of
calling up here in 14 days due diligence
periods for them to and everything is
listed in the terms and conditions to
protect both parties so
we always make sure before you know that
they before they pay they have to sign
that um because it protects us and
protects them as well yeah yeah and
that's so important because otherwise
there could be lack of clarity and then
if you sell a deal to somebody
six months later they go oh man i want
my money back because the roof's leaking
and it's like well hang on whoa what
does the contract say so it's so
important to have that yeah um what are
your plans then over the next um sort of
six months
six months so i'm going to be full time
in the next two weeks yeah
so i'm planning have you quit yet um not
yet so actually with teaching actually
um
i want to do um get money from property
because i want to teach because i want
to not because i have to so you're still
going to do a bit i'm going to do a bit
maybe um maybe just a part time it will
actually work
no because actually maybe not
necessarily the um
what you're exactly you know the
curriculum out yeah eventually i want to
teach um on property and then because i
like the skill of teaching where does
that come from where does the desire to
help kids and young people actually
understand finances like talk to me
about that because you know that's
something that i'm passionate about yeah
i think i think just
it's just god just put that on my heart
to just help him just teach and and i
feel like that's that's my purpose yeah
whether whether it's in a school whether
it's in uh you know in other different
environments yeah
and bother parents with teachers yeah
one that kind of explains how we brought
in
that
what's your what's your motivation what
would you say your strongest reason is
for doing this business um in terms of
like i want to create time so i can live
purposefully so i can do the projects
that i want to do i know as a christian
i want to make sure you know the gospel
reached out to many people and the love
of christ
you know it's reached out to many people
so you know you know i just wanna make
sure that you know my time is not
constricted um by you know doing a job
or i wanna
if i have a job i wanna choose to if i
can work there rather than i have to so
yeah creating that time and you know and
making sure my family's looked after
yeah that's great and what would you say
to somebody that was wanting to get into
property just do it because the crash
course
if you ain't got money
watch all the youtube videos learn as
much as you can
save up money go for the trade and just
do it yeah because that's not that much
like 2 000 now it doesn't sound like
money like other people tell them like i
bet three kids
it doesn't sound like a lot of money to
you because you've done it you've done
but before
you're forgetting what you you know
before like i remember paying that 2000.
and i was a bit nervous
but when before i went to the training
and i was like
and then um so not many people knew that
i was even doing property so yeah
yeah
what would that say if you just told
them you dropped two thousand on a
course so so obviously these people have
you know
that's more pressure on me
know that you know there's enough money
for everyone you know even if people
want to start you know have the
knowledge take action yeah you know have
that persistence you know i believe is
so important because if you don't
believe that you're gonna do it yeah
then you already failed yeah yeah people
fail before they even begin because
that's the thing people decide are never
spent two grand on the training program
it's that they clearly don't think
they're going to make that much money
some people say to me i'll give you 50
of my business if you teach me for free
and it's like
you clearly don't think you're going to
be very successful because if you're
saying i'm prepared to give half of my
business
just to save a few brands
that shouldn't be that i will do that no
business is worth a lot right but i bet
you would have six months ago yes it
would have been
[Music]
when you got your first deal and you
started people started investing in
you're paying your three round three
round four and five grand because you've
invested in yourself it's easy to ask
people to invest in you it's like oh i
found this deal it's three grand but if
you'd only ever watched three videos on
youtube taking three four grand off
somebody you might feel a bit oh
unworthy and because you feel unworthy
they might never come
but when you invest in yourself i think
that people start then investing in you
yeah
you know um how did you justify how did
you justify the decision at the time
because you didn't know what was going
to happen
so how did i justify i think i'm always
prepared to take calculated risk yeah
because because with your training i
knew that energy i know i i i just knew
that okay from someone i connected in
terms of like you know as a christian
fellow brother as well so that i just
felt that you know what let me just try
it out you know what's the worst that
can happen and just you know get that
2000. the best way to predict the future
is to create it
so if you're thinking oh is it going to
work am i going to be successful don't
worry about what's going to happen just
make it happen
you've got to just decide what you want
to do and as you said just go do it
exactly you know
write that down every time you talk i
must take your notes
so what will be your final words of
wisdom and advice for the folks
listening in
i'll say just do it don't doubt it just
do it and give yourself like a time
frame at least say give us a moment for
two months yeah i'm gonna go home i'm
gonna go every day i'm gonna wake up and
just try as hard as i can
and if it doesn't work it doesn't work
but it's going to work love it i would
say belief and mindset yeah like you
need to believe you can do it
you need to have the right mindset if
you look if you haven't got the right
mindset maybe you need to look at your
environment
yeah the environment is stronger than
willpower so you need to have that
environment because it's good when you
come to the training course it's high
energy but then when you go back home
like where you what environment are you
going back to so you know so i say
belief and man are very important and
what makes you guys decide to team up
and where did you meet
um so we met in school really yeah
it was like mums were friends yeah it
just made it made sense for us to be
friends and why did you decide to do
this business so i was i was actually i
had this i had this um training i had so
many um strategies but then i didn't
have the time and he was at the time he
was transitioning so he was time rich so
i just thought it made sense yeah you
know to you know someone who actually
he's got time to to to go do these
viewings and because he was in the
transition um so i just thought you know
what and they know it's relentless
energy to really go you know um to go
for it well you guys make great business
partners yeah and i'm really pleased to
see what you've done man so big respect
here for you in the next stages and um i
look forward to seeing you continue to
win man thanks
appreciate it thank you